>>> THERE'S THE WHITE HOUSE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ON A MISSION
TO SELL HIS MORE THAN $2
TRILLION INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AT HIS FIRST CABINET MEETING
YESTERDAY, MR. BIDEN NAMED
COMMERCE SECRETARY GINA RAIMONDO
AND FOUR OTHER SECRETARIES TO
HELP WITH THE PUSH.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
NANCY CORDES SPOKE WITH THE
COMMERCE SECRETARY ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S HISTORIC PROPOSAL.
NANCY, GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
COMMERCE SECRETARY GINA RAIMONDO
IS A FORMER RHODES SCHOLAR.
THE FORMER RHODE ISLAND GOVERNOR
WHO LED HER STATE'S RECOVERY
BACK FROM THE HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN THE
COUNTRY.
SHE'S NOW TRYING TO REPLICATE
SOME OF THAT SUCCESS ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL.
WE SAT DOWN WITH SECRETARY
RAIMONDO ON HER 28th BATH
RUNNING AN AGENCY -- DAY RUNNING
AN AGENCY THAT ENCOMPASSES
EVERYTHING FROM THE NATIONAL
WEATHER SERVICE TO THE U.S.
CENSUS BUREAU.
>> WE DO A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERYTHING.
WE DEAL WITH FISH AND FISHERIES.
WE HAVE AN OFFICE OF SPACE
COMMERCE.
THE WAY I THINK ABOUT IT IS IT'S
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH MAKING
SURE AMERICA CAN COMPETE.
>> Reporter: YOU WERE ON THE
SHORT LIST FOR A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT CABINET-LEVEL
POSITIONS.
WHAT MADE YOU WANT TO RUN THE
COMMERCE DEPARTMENT?
>> JOBS.
JOBS, JOBS, JOBS.
GETTING AMERICANS BACK TO WORK.
EVERY AMERICAN DESERVES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR DECENT PAYING
JOBS, PERIOD.
>> GINA RAIMONDO --
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT BIDEN
GAVE HER A JOB YESTERDAY --
SELLING HIS NEW $2 TRILLION
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN AND THE
CORPORATE TAX HIKE DESIGNED TO
PAY FOR IT.
YOU MUST HAVE BUSINESS LEADERS
BLOWING UP YOUR PHONE ALREADY
SAYING DON'T INCREASE THE
CORPORATE TAX RATE, IT'S GOING
TO HURT US, IT'S GOING TO SLOW
THE RECOVERY.
>> TRUTHFULLY, I DON'T.
>> Reporter: REALLY?
WILL.
>> WHAT I AM HEARING IS WE NEED
THESE INVESTMENTS.
WE NEED THE TRAINED WORK FORCE.
YES, THERE WILL BE SOME GROUSING
IF THERE ARE INCREASES IN
CORPORATE TAXES.
BUT AS LONG AS OUR CORPORATE TAX
RATE IS COMPETITIVE, I THINK
OVERALL THEY'RE GOING TO BE
HAPPY FOR THE HISTORIC
INVESTMENT.
>> TO GET AS MANY PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK --
>> Reporter: RAIMONDO IS EAGER
TO EXPAND ON A BACK-TO-WORK
INITIATIVE SHE IMPLEMENTED IN
RHODE ISLAND TO COMBAT PANDEMIC
JOB LOSSES.
>> WE WILL HIRE YOU.
>> Reporter: THERE SHE PUT $45
MILLION IN FEDERAL STIMULUS INTO
RETRAINING DISPLACED EMPLOYEES
FOR HIGH-SKILL, HIGHER PAYING
JOBS.
>> WE NEED TO MAKE MORE THINGS
IN AMERICA AND PUT PEOPLE TO
WORK DOING IT.
MY DAD WORKED HIS WHOLE CAREER
MAKING WATCHES ANIN PROVIDENCE,
RHODE ISLAND.
EVERY MORNING HE GOT IN HIS
CARPOOL WITH HIM AND HIS
BUDDIES, THEY WENT TO THE
FACTORY.
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE ALL THOSE
JOBS INCLUDING HIS WENT
OVERSEAS.
>> Reporter: A LOT OF
POLITICIANS PROMISE THAT THEY
CAN BRING MANUFACTURING BACK TO
THE U.S.
WHAT'S REALISTIC AND WHAT ISN'T?
>> THAT IS AN EXCELLENT QUESTION
BECAUSE NOT EVERYTHING CAN COME
BACK.
MANUFACTURING TODAY ISN'T MY
DAD'S MANUFACTURING, YOU KNOW.
IT'S NOT LOW SKILL, LOW WAGE.
THAT ISN'T GOING TO COME BACK TO
AMERICA.
WHAT WILL COME BACK IS THE
HIGHER SKILL, HIGHER TECH MORE
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING, AND THAT
COMES BACK WITH A COMBINATION OF
BASIC RESEARCH AND TRAINING, AND
THEN FAIR TRADE POLICY.
WE CAN'T LET CHINA EAT OUR
LUNCH.
AND SO WE HAVE TO BE AGGRESSIVE
TO STICK UP FOR AMERICAN WORKERS
AND BUSINESSES.
>> Reporter: LET'S TALK ABOUT
CHINA.
YOU HAVE ACTUALLY SAID THAT YOUR
PREDECESSORS' TARIFFS HAVE
WORKED TO SOME DEGREE.
YOU THINK THAT THAT WAS THE
RIGHT APPROACH?
>> CHINA HAS SHOWN IT'S WILLING
TO DO ESSENTIALLY WHATEVER IT
TAKES.
THEY'LL STEAL OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY, USE TECHNOLOGY FOR
MILITARY PURPOSES.
SO THAT MEANS WE NEED TO BE
STRATEGIC, AGGRESSIVE, AND HAVE
A WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH.
YOU KNOW, IT'S GAME ON, AND MY
BET'S ON AMERICA.
>> Reporter: ONE OF HER MOST
PRESSING CHALLENGES -- THE
GENDER GAP.
ALMOST THREE MILLION AMERICAN
WOMEN HAVE LEFT OR LOST THEIR
JOBS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
>> NOT ONLY HAVE THEY FALLEN OUT
OF THE WORK FORCE IN GREATER
NUMBERS, BUT IN LARGE PART WE'RE
THE ONES WHO HAVE BEEN JUGGLING
BETWEEN TEACHING THE KIDS AT
HOME, TAKING CARE OF THE KIDS AT
HOME, AND WORKING.
>> Reporter: DID COVID CREATE
NEW INEQUITIES FOR WOMEN, OR DID
IT JUST EXPOSE INEQUITIES THAT
WERE ALREADY THERE?
>> I THINK BOTH.
FOR ALL OF US IT SHOULD BE A
WAKE-UP CALL.
LIKE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT BUILDING
BACK BETTER IT MEANS BUILDING
BACK MORE EQUALLY.
>> Reporter: ONE PIECE OF
LEFTOVER WORK FROM THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION IS LAST YEAR'S
CENSUS.
SECRETARY RAIMONDO TOLD ME THAT
THE DATA DELAYED BY THE PANDEMIC
MAY NOT BE READY UNTIL SEPTEMBER
WHICH IS WELL PAST THE DEADLINE
FOR SOME STATES TO REDRAW THEIR
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS IN TIME
FOR THE 2022 MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
AND OF COURSE THIS ALL COMES AT
A TIME, GAYLE, WHEN THERE'S A
NATIONAL DEBATE RAGING OVER
ACCESS TO THE BALLOT BOX.
>> THAT DATA IS VERY IMPORTANT.
I REMEMBER FILLING OUT MY
QUESTIONNAIRE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, NANCY.
THANKS A LOT.
I LIKE HOW THE COMMERCE
SECRETARY'S THINKING.
SHE SAYS, "GAME ON," AND S